[Music]
foreign
you're almost here
you go
[Music]
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place it's a shrine
guys
we've gotta lure him in
we execute him
come on mother
it's for you
in theaters March 10th tickets on sale
now
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a total dick oh please he left
out some important information but
that is the gist of it
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
perfect
foreign
my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family and
how we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are
building This Magnificent family
going on in that head of yours something
little piece of it isn't dead
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear
boom
you built such a beautiful life filled
with love and family I never got that
chance
you stole that from me my
future my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
Peace by peace
[Music]
[Applause]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
[Music]
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
never accept death when suffering is old
yet
[Music]
he's trying to tear us apart
today I race to stop the bloodbath
[Music]
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
Let's Race
[Music]
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
I'm coming for you son
thank you
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]
foreign
death Island
have we met my memory is a little fuzzy
are you still a Nazi
[Music]
ers
oh
it was all a dream the name's Mirage
come on kill tap okay
relax a mirage remember
[Music]
here I come cause I'm ready
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
but he doesn't anymore
I'm just getting started little brother
I'm coming for everything
[Applause]
don't let him destroy everything you've
built
here I come
tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay
fight to save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with magnets
[Music]
my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
is happening
completely broke the universe
outside we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
you're you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
Miss Cara Barry
foreign
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
is she using the leaf to blot her tears
it would be weird to give her tissue
Mira we made children's books maybe it's
better to prepare them life will
inevitably Crush their hopes and dreams
[Music]
you know I'm just wearing my dead
boyfriend's shirt and texting is all
numbered
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of
these I have a phone you have a personal
phone this is a work phone
I miss you so much there's a naked
inside of me
do you have a question for me yes Mr do
you really believe in all these things
you sing you obviously know nothing
about it what love
[Music]
don't you passed I still can't believe
it who is sending me these texts every
morning I open my eyes hoping I'll still
see you I must have the dead boyfriend's
number that's super sad I think they're
nice there is nothing wrong with putting
yourself back out there again you're
going there get the D you make it sound
like I have a vitamin deficiency yeah
you kind of do you have a vitamin D
deficiency because when the sun comes up
maybe we just take it a little slower
they're never gonna hold me down I think
I might have feelings for someone I've
never met please fix your receiving or
saying something it might be crazy but
love doesn't always follow the rules
[Music]
I'm wearing it to the Opera tonight
these are from a literal stranger I just
need to put a face to these texts
[Music]
I'm not sure oh my God you should pay
yourself a date the normal way she
thinks I am interesting you need to tell
her the truth you should have said
something to her right away
again
I was looking forward to this I just
felt like I knew you or something do you
think you could fall in love with
someone just through their words I think
you're very cute
the more I get to know her the better I
like her
[Music]
it's like this don't just happen love is
a plan for each and every one of us
hi this is Celine Dion sure and I'm
Mariah Carey love comes to those who
believe it and this is really me oh my
gosh hi
[Music]
okay get in here
I don't know how you sleep with all
these lights
what are you scared of
I don't see anything
okay monster check complete
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
in the dark
it's like all those spooky monsters you
think are hiding under your bed
[Music]
it's not real
what is this
[Music]
late that comes for your kids when
you're not paying attention
[Music]
you believe me
don't you
listen to me George you got a punch like
I've never seen But in every battle the
greatest show that we will come back
isn't here
I live one way your whole life heavenly
father thank you for this food George
should change his name from four man the
poor man
what's my name now is the new
heavyweight champion of the workers
don't have any rage
and it becomes all you know let's thank
God for the food y'all I bought the food
do I say nothing George
God stop we thought he was dead
a worse
I'm done I'm not going to box anymore do
you know what you're walking away from
sir I want to spread the word of God and
what I saw
How's being a preacher going for you
it's hard harder than getting punched in
the face
sometimes it feels about the same hey
money enjoy yourself
power companies said we never paid the
bill really it's only two things I know
how to do that's box you preach and
preaching won't pay the bills
made me something once yeah you can do
it again
it is my destiny to win the heavyweight
championship belt again
last time they saw me I looked like
Superman and now you look like the
mission in there this ain't no beauty
contest
Michael Moore he's 26 and Unstoppable
how can you beat that noise
in this young man's game
[Music]
Mr Foreman that funny little Grill deal
you signed is starting to generate some
substantial checks really now I'm just
surprised this show is a big old fat guy
like me to sell a beer to help people
get lean
I probably should have asked this
earlier but how much cash do you have on
you did you not bring enough money to
come to this game I brought like 80.
minus 60. I'm ready
what's up with your boy he's almost done
I'm like the PT Anderson of basketball
psychological warfare who is PT Anderson
our greatest living director Spike Lee
is our greatest living director Spike
Lee's not even a good Knicks fan
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
the company
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I don't remember any of it
I only remember
The Interpreter
[Music]
why he wants his job I need the money
don't disappoint turn out to be a pain
in the ass no not me sir
money isn't the reason he wants this job
and Taliban killed his son
we don't want to go down this road
you're out of your bounds Ahmed you're
here translating actually I'm here to
interpret
Howie's approaching
well I want
back down for three weeks this family
believed you were dead we owed a man
your life there wasn't enough for him to
carry me across those mountains
no he's hiding in a hole somewhere I
should be in that hole
everything all right John no
everything's not all right there is a
hook in me Ahmed and his family are in
trouble we can't intervene
I am gonna actually beat him out myself
listen you're gonna be alone
you go to adapt
this is what you got
if you can give me the location if I can
get them out of the country it's too
dangerous
you become very popular with the Taliban
I miss you love you Daddy
if I could be free of this debt I
wouldn't be
you think I have a choice
there is no choice no I won't
back down
I'm Sophie I'm Tim for a young man
passing it about music there's no
greater place to be than mozarts
instrumental show me what you got
enough
[Music]
where did you go last night
do you believe me do I believe that
o'clock in the school there's a portal
into Mozart's club and Masterpiece no
[Music]
what are you doing back there I have no
idea where I am
the young friends
bring back my beloved daughter
ready even at the Peril of death well
I'm not sure about the whole Peril of
Death part you shouldn't take a risk if
you're gonna figure out what it is
you're missing
you know to rescue
[Music]
foreign
I need right here how about a challenge
high stakes
I'm in this job is not like any other
job
what are we stealing
a painting
four paintings wait what it's the most
beautiful art the world has ever known
each one of you is the best at what you
do
the paintings we're getting back were
stolen by Nazis during World War II so
not a standard smashing ground this
money got us killed
you will never get my paintings
so what's the play these guys are
dangerous
we just need them incapacitated not hurt
I can do it I know a little dishes
we got a problem
under control
what are we walking into here
holy that's not a safe and that's a
fault it's cool it's awesome love it
we're trying to right a wrong Against
Humanity
someone tell me what the hell is going
on this is bigger than us what's
happening you want to trust they know
we're coming
what they used to do to save the Nazi
Germany
oh hold up hold up is that nuclear
tell me who is this guy comes in here
has the balls to jeopardize everything
we were for maybe he's a cop maybe he's
with the feds nah and with the law
no law would do what he did
only time I worried about him was the
first time I met him
I just don't very much a part of me just
Dallas characters but Lars in a really
bad spot with the bikers in the cartel
I'm gonna find out who's working for and
then I'm gonna kill him
word on the street is he's offering 5
million for anyone who can bring it to
him
well it's a whole lot of reasons isn't
it
Dallas sounds like somebody's trying to
cover the trash you need to get out now
let's get this over with
we got him shut him off
when he gets here he's gonna kill you
made a weapon he can't control it
to find Lars I need to finish this
[Music]
we are gonna have to take control
wait
[Music]
why'd you come back I mean welcome back
now
don't want to be in his life you know
[Music]
and you can't come back
and have it go back to normal
she's gonna fight or something
yeah
did you get yours
no
she walked out on us
I had that little boy you used to know
the left left right there's some things
about my past I can't have you around
that
stay away
[Music]
got a disease in your heart
let's go Dairy be relaxed we can go kick
it do not talk to him
he's always pretending to be this person
I know he's not
what's your name man Darius
nice to meet you there
nice to meet you too
[Music]